flagge zeigen am tag der arbeit der dgb
wird für solidarität weitere mai demos
verlaufen bislang weitgehend ruhig
hilfsflug für indien die bundeswehr
liefert 120 beatmungsgeräte das land
verzeichnet einen rekordwert von 400.000
corona neuinfektionen an einem tag
polarisierende kandidat ex
verfassungsschutzpräsident maßen will
für die cdu in den bundestag das führt
parteiintern zu kritik
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten amt willkommen zu
den heute -nachrichten am ersten mai
norbert lehmann hat die vom sport dabei
in ca 12 minuten 1 sekunden an topfit
es ist der zweite tag der arbeit in
corona zeiten und er wirft ein
schlaglicht auf die situation vieler
beschäftigter solidarität habe in der
pandemie zwar das schlimmste verhindert
sagt der deutsche gewerkschaftsbund die
folgen der krise seien aber enorm
die gewerkschaften hatten wieder zu
ihren kundgebungen aufgerufen doch nicht
nur sie auch gegen die korona maßnahmen
demonstrierten heute wieder viele ebenso
sammelten sich rechte und neonazis gegen
die sich wiederum linke gegendemos
formierten aber zunächst zur
eigentlichen veranstaltung der zentralen
kundgebung des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbunds diesmal in hamburg
sven regn berichtet oder stolle hat viel
durchgemacht im vergangenen jahr die
karstadt betriebsrätin musste mit
ansehen wie ihr unternehmen ein haus
nach dem anderen dicht machte die allein
in hamburg 300 beschäftigte gehen
mussten
jetzt kämpft sich für alle angestellten
im einzelhandel über 70 der
arbeitsplätze im handel von frauen
belegt werden
die situation im handel und in der
pflege die solidarität der wohlhabenden
für die gewerkschaften hat dieser erste
mal viele themen die pandemie steht über
allem
über 200 teilnehmer konnten daher die
forderungen des gewerkschaftsbundes in
hamburg hören wir brauchen ein
ambitioniertes
zukunftsinvestitionsprogramm um
digitalisierung den klimawandel zu
bewältigen
das geht nur mit investitionen und
beteiligung der menschen der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer der
green deal muss immer auch ein social
diese
in münchen und vielen anderen städten
fanden weitere veranstaltungen statt den
nachmittag über schalteten sich
ortsverbände in einem live stream
zusammen alles unter dem motto
solidarität ist zukunft auch bei den
löhnen
ich finde es ist ein schandfleck des
deutschen sozialstaates das 30 jahre
nach der wiedervereinigung immer noch
von den arbeitgebern verhindert wird
dass endlich die arbeits und entgelte
sie sich ein gleichen für oder stolle
war die gewerkschaftsarbeit ein
lichtblick gemeinsam mit vielen anderen
beschäftigten hat sie an der elbe
einiges erreicht zwei karstadt häuser
bleiben vorerst erhalten
schauen wir nach berlin auf den straßen
der hauptstadt war und ist einiges los
gut zwanzig sehr unterschiedliche
protestaktionen mit insgesamt rund
10.000 teilnehmern die größte demo
findet am abend statt im einsatz mehr
als 5000 beamte in ganz deutschland ein
wirklicher tag der arbeit für die
polizei
stephanie heim
schon am nachmittag zogen rund 1000
menschen gegen die korona regeln durch
den berliner bezirk lichtenberg
begleitet von etlichen gegenprotesten in
leipzig wurden die demonstrationen von
rechten gruppen verboten einige hundert
gegendemonstrant innen kamen trotzdem um
für eine solidarische gesellschaft in
der pandemie zu kämpfen
in weimar versammelten sich nach
polizeiangaben um die tausend menschen
um ihre solidarität mit einem richter zu
zeigen
der gegen die masken pflicht an schulen
geurteilt hatte die stadt weimar hatte
die veranstaltung verboten und das
amtsgericht abgesperrt im ganzen
berliner stadtgebiet forderten mehrere
tausend radelnd die umverteilung des
reichtums und die enteignung großer
wohnungskonzern trotz infektionsschutz
verordnung demonstrationen sind erlaubt
das infektionsschutzgesetz sieht
tatsächlich direkt ausnahmen für die
versammlungsfreiheit und die
religionsfreiheit übrigens vor so dass
zum beispiel die ausgangssperre nach 22
uhr die ja nach 22 uhr gilt eben nicht
für den bereich der versammlungen gilt
auf der anderen seite darf man aber
nicht vergessen
versammlungs anmelderin und anmelder
also sprich die versammlungsleitung auch
die müssen ein tragfähiges konzept
vorlegen auf dessen einhaltung die
polizei weiter achten will auch bei der
sogenannten revolutionären 1 mai
demonstration in berlin kreuzberg
und genau da beobachtet stephan
merseburger die lage für uns stefan es
gibt ein großaufgebot der polizei hat
die denn viel zu tun natürlich die
polizei hat jede menge zu tun 20
demonstrationen heute in berlin darunter
natürlich die traditionelle
revolutionäre demonstration zum ersten
mal von linken und linksradikalen
gruppen bis zu 10.000 teilnehmer werden
erwartet sich diese demonstration ist ja
weit über berlin hinaus bekannt weil es
immer wieder zu ausschreitungen und
krawallen gekommen ist das hat die
polizei in den letzten jahren eigentlich
ganz gut in den griff bekommen mit einer
gezielten strategie von deeskalation
einerseits und andererseits den
gezielten herausgreifen von
gewaltbereiten personen in diesem jahr
kommt wir haben zum beitrag
gehört die ausgangssperre dazu was
passiert wenn sich die demonstration
erst nach 22 uhr auflöst dann wird die
polizei die teilnehmer beherzt und
nachhaltig nachdrücklich dazu auffordern
schnell nach hause zu gehen
ja sie bleiben wir für uns vor ort
vielen dank dafür stephan merseburger
der blick auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen sie sind erneut gesunken
das robert koch institut registrierte
innerhalb von 24 stunden 18 1935
neuinfektionen
das sind 4400 57 weniger als vor einer
woche
232 todesfälle kamen dazu die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents fällt
weiter auf jetzt 148,6 deutschland hilft
dem besonders hart von der korona
pandemie getroffenen indien
am vormittag ist in köln eine erste
maschine mit hilfsmaterial gestartet an
bord sind 120 beatmungsgeräte
medikamente und 13 mitglieder des
bundeswehr sanitätsdienstes sie sollen
vor ort mitarbeiter des roten kreuzes an
lernen eine sauerstoff anlage der
bundeswehr zu bedienen
in indien brechen nämlich wichtige teile
des gesundheitssystems zusammen
als erstes land weltweit registrierte es
an einem tag mehr als 400.000
neuinfektionen seit mitte märz steigt
diese kurve dramatisch an
allein gestern starben über 3500
menschen normen odenthal über die
katastrophale lage im land
sie hat es ins holy family hospital
geschafft und das ist viel wert
eigentlich eines der besten
krankenhäuser delhis privat gut
ausgestattet aber in diesen tagen gilt
das nichts mehr
sie sind nicht am anschlag sie sind
längst darüber auch hier
es ist sehr schön schlimmer als schlimm
das ist keine krise das ist verheerender
furchtbarer ich kann es nur so sagen
an diesem punkt ist das wort krise eine
untertreibung
es geht ums überleben für jeden wohin
das führt kann man spüren kann man sehen
schlange stehen für sauerstoff das
kostbarste gut in diesen tagen und
mangelware noch immer auch die apotheken
werden gestürmt jede pille die hoffnung
verspricht wird gekauft alles wird knapp
und dadurch werden die leute nur noch
panischer sie kaufen das doppelte
dreifache von dem was sie brauchen und
andere gehen dadurch leer aus auch der
impfstoff der die rettung sein soll
fehlt alle ab 18 sollen sich ab heute
spritzen lassen hat die regierung
vollmundig verkündet der gute plan
scheitert an der harten realität
wir tun was wir können aber wir bitten
unsere bürger um verständnis steht nicht
schlange vor den impfzentren wir können
euch jetzt noch nicht impfen denn wir
haben die vakzine nicht wir hoffen dass
sich das schnell ändern
hoffnung allerdings hat gerade einen
schweren stand in einem krankenhaus in
good charlotte perriand die
intensivstation ab ursache unbekannt 18
menschen sterben es ist als kasseler
alles unglück auf indien hernieder
wenn sie den menschen in indien helfen
wollen in ihrem kampf gegen das virus
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
freut sich über ihre spende stichwort
zdf chor ohne hilfe weltweit bahn.de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen finden sie im internet
unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190 baden württemberg
wird weiter von grün schwarz regiert man
habe sich auf eine neuauflage des
bündnisses geeinigt teilten sprecher von
grünen und cdu mit der koalitionsvertrag
wird am mittwoch vorgestellt klimaschutz
ist ein schwerpunkt zwei andere der
ausbau des nahverkehrs sowie des
schnellen internets die cdu im süden
thüringens will ihre chancen bei der
bundestagswahl steigern indem sie ein
besonders umstrittenen direktkandidaten
ins rennen schickt hans-georg maßen
der musste 2018 als chef des bundesamts
für verfassungsschutz gehen weil er in
frage stellte dass es nach der tötung
eines deutschen in chemnitz hetzjagden
auf ausländer gegeben hatte sein
politisches comeback bereitet vielen
unbehagen auch in der union
florian coaching es sind schlagzeilen
auf die die unionsspitzen den bund und
land lieber verzichtet hätten
bei vielen gilt hans georg maßen als zu
polarisierend zu weit am rechten rand
auch thüringens cdu chef hirte hatte die
basis vor der nominierung gewarnt doch
die ist ihm nicht gefolgt die bürger in
den neuen bundesländern sind auch
aufmüpfiger gegen die obrigkeit mir
jedenfalls ist ziemlich deutlich
signalisiert worden dass man eine
mischung von oben nicht akzeptieren wird
am abend wurde es amtlich
danach gibt sich maßen ganz auf
parteilinie
er stehe hinter kanzlerkandidat laschet
und schließe eine zusammenarbeit mit der
ard aus mein anliegen ist es mit meiner
reputation und mit meiner anhängerschaft
nicht durchaus habe auch dafür zu sorgen
dass wir der afd
und auch anderen parteien die stimmen
wegnehmen stimmen wegnehmen die die cdu
hier zuletzt vor allem an die fdp
verloren hat masons neuer wahlkreis in
südthüringen gilt als besonders
konservativ
hinsichtlich der person will man
deutlich machen dass man für eine sagen
wir mal konservativere cdu steht als
jede aktuelle bundesvorstand
repräsentiert und auch in dieser
hinsicht will man nach innen was die
partei angeht wirken aber natürlich auch
nach außen auf die wählerinnen und
wähler cdu-chef laschet tritt heute bei
einer gewerkschaftskundgebung in
düsseldorf auf zur personalie maßen will
er sich gegenüber den zdf nicht äußern
zum fussball und zu den halbfinals im
dfb-pokal norbert ja heute abend spielt
der bvb gegen holstein kiel um den
einzug ins finale der gegner dort der
steht ja schon fest es ist rb leipzig
nach dem last minute sieg in der
verlängerung gegen werder bremen gestern
abend der traum vom perfekten abschied
aus leipzig lebt für julia nagelsmann
weiter dank e mail forsberg und seiner
akrobatik einlagen kurz vor abpfiff
während die meisten spieler
wahrscheinlich schon mit dem
elfmeterschießen rechnen
nutzt der schwede die letzte chance von
rb dass zwei zu eins der lohn in der
verlängerung für einen unerwartet harten
arbeitstag nach 90 torlosen minuten
lässt pokal-spezialisten wann die
sachsen das erste mal jubeln
sein drittes tor im vierten spiel doch
bremen bis zum schluss kämpferisch an
diesem abend bittencourt der ausgleich
die schlusspointe gehört aber den gästen
rb zum zweiten mal im pokalfinale für
julia nagelsmann die chance seine zeit
in leipzig zu krönen
und leipzig sport vorstand markus
krösche der wird nächste saison in
derselben funktion bei eintracht
frankfurt arbeiten als nachfolger von
fredi bobic tennis profi jan lennard
struff hat zum ersten mal in seiner
karriere ein endspiel bei einem atp
turnier erreicht in münchen siegte der
31 jährige im halbfinale mit 6 zu 4 und
6 zu 1 gegen wacker aus belarus der
gestern noch gegen die deutsche nummer
eins alexander zverev gewonnen hatte
bayern münchens basketballer träumen
weiter vom halbfinaleinzug in der
euroleague gestern abend im vierten
spiel der best of five der ausgleich zum
2 2 gegen mailand dabei sah es lange
zeit gar nicht so gut aus für die bayern
ein krachender dunk kurz nach der pause
scheint bayerns halbfinal hoffnungen zu
zerstören mailand mit 13 punkten vorne
doch die münchner kämpften sich zurück
20 sekunden vor schluss bedient paul
zipser spektakulär wladimir lucic
ausgleich mit dem ausscheiden vor augen
gehen zipse bluechips volles risiko und
weil der serbe in der hektischen
schlussphase die nerven behält und noch
drei freiwürfe versenkt gewinnen die
bayern mit 85 zu 82 ein fast schon
verlorenes spiel und die entscheidung
über den finaleinzug die fitteren
dienstag in 50 letzten spielen da genau
wird und wir werfen auch einen blick auf
das wetter im westen freundlich und
meist trocken sonst wolken und regen
besonders dauerhaft am morgen im osten
und süden bei lebhaften nordwestwind 8
bis 15 grad
das war es an diesem ersten mal danke
für ihr interesse
christian sievers erwartet sie im heute
journal heute erst um 23 uhr 15
und wir freuen uns morgen abend um
sieben wieder auf sie einen schönen
restlichen feiertag wünschen
[Musik]